[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour le
7-8 week-end actualité et idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le sommaire de
ce 4 mars la course aux parrainages
prend fin ce vendredi 4 mars pour les
candidats à la présidentielle il
s'agissait de recueillir les 500
signatures nécessaires pour se présenter
au premier tour de l'élection les élus
lillois ont été sollicités nous verrons
à qui ils ont accordé leur parrainage la
course au soleil est de retour dans les
yvelines comme chaque année depuis 2010
le grand départ de paris nice sera donné
dans le département un village
d'animation propose tout un tas
d'activités et de villes sont encore à
l'honneur cette année et puis comme tous
les vendredis nos idées de sorties dans
les mines pour le week-end mais aussi
les tout derniers rendez vous pour les
vacances d'hiver qui prennent fin ce
dimanche des idées que vous retrouverez
bien sûr en deuxième partie d'émission
et bixente mahé 1 106 stevan bonjour
bonjour maladie qu'est ce que vous nous
avez dégoter cette semaine et bien déjà
je vais m'associer aussi un peu à vous
pour parler du paris nice bien sûr et on
prévoit aussi par exemple une petite
promenade à cheval là vous verrez ça
tout à l'heure en fin d'émission un peu
de politique vendredi 4 mars à 18 heures
ce sont les dates et heures de clôture
de dépôt des parrainages pour les
prétendants à l'élection présidentielle
d'avril prochain les candidats doivent
ont validé au moins 500 pour se
présenter lors des scrutins dans les
yvelines 156 élus ont apporté leur tour
d'horizon
c'est sans surprise que valérie pécresse
obtient le plus de parrainages d'élus
yvelinois la candidate les républicains
en rassemble sans quelques heures avant
la clôture des dépôts emmanuel macron en
rassemble lui 29 la candidate du
rassemblement national en a obtenu 4 2
conseillers régionaux du même groupe
politique et de maire se de mousseaux
sur scène et scintiller la ville j'ai
quelque chose qui pas du tout un soutien
rien à voir je pars année une personne
en qui je ne voterai pas mais je
considère que
c'est un devoir républicain de boire
que les gens qui ont quelque chose à
dire à défendre puisqu'ils se faire du
côté des autres candidats d'extrême
droite eric zemmour recueille 3
parrainage ceux des maires de mu s'en
offrir ville brasseur et le tartre
godrans le maire des vêtements a choisi
françois asselineau seul candidat est
revenue à sa rencontre comme le maire de
saintes huiles et la ville sont tarés
nage ne signifie pas soutien j'avoue que
le collègue qui n'épargne personne parce
que le conseil municipal va les suivre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de retour du
retour de certains habitants
alors que bon faut bien le mauvais
candidat à l'élection suprême
pour moi c'est un acte démocratique on
doit faire des parrainages ont aussi été
apportées aux candidats de gauche après
noël mamère françois hollande et
emmanuel macron le maire divers gauche
des mureaux a choisi l'édile de paris
anne hidalgo j'ai toujours pas une
équipe pour parler de ce soir à lille
malgré en 2017 et pour une cause je vous
savez j'étais en accord avec lui on
avait discuté là aujourd'hui je n'avais
pas de candidat qui me satisfaisait aux
sociaux-démocrates assez à cette époque
là là je pense aujourd'hui j'ai amené
mon parrainage à hidalgo ou une simple
raison c'est qu'aujourd'hui je pense
aussi les fortes social démocratie
doivent être représentées tout comme le
maire des mureaux à lire ab associe son
parrainage un soutien le maire de
trappes a fait le choix du candidat de
la france insoumise jean luc mélenchon
j'estime que 2022 et une échéance
importante est que nous avons un vrai
débat nous avons besoin de pouvoir avoir
des projets qui s'affrontent qui ne
représente pas forcément les mêmes
intérêts mais les français doivent
pouvoir choisir c'est cela la démocratie
elle les élus rencontrés pour ce
reportage ont pour la plupart regretté
le manque d'anonymat pour les
parrainages à ce jour onze candidats ont
atteint les 500 requis
une semaine marquée par le conflit en
ukraine du football ou encore la
disparition de jean pierre pernaut
grégory canal et nous résume cette
semaine en 78 secondes
[Musique]
un sommet de l'europe de la défense ces
manuels macro réunira les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement les 10 et 11 mars au
château de versailles le président de la
république l'a révélé lors de son
discours sur le conflit en ukraine la
mobilisation s'organise dans les
yvelines en soutien à la population
ukrainienne le préfet jean jacques brot
a demandé au maire de recenser les
possibilités d'hébergement des familles
de son côté le département a que huit
jeunes ukrainiens au campus des mureaux
solidarité également dans de nombreuses
communes qui organisent des collectes en
lien avec les associations la gerbe
installé à ecquevilly a fait partir 10
tonnes de matériel par camion fin de
parcours pour versailles en coupe de
france les footballeurs et guînois ont
été éliminés avec les honneurs contre
nice en demi-finale le score 2 à 0
environ 80 supporters ont fait le
déplacement dans le sud les versailles
est également très présent dans les bars
de la cité royale pour suivre la
rencontre le salon de l'agriculture au
programme jusqu'au 6 mars à paris et
pour cette 58e édition les producteurs
yvelinois sont au rendez vous enfin il
était justement un amoureux des
territoires jean pierre pernaut a
succombé à un cancer des poumons
présentateur du 13 heures de tf1 entre
1988 et 2020 il habitait les yvelines à
louveciennes les habitants se
souviennent d'un homme sympathique et
engagé jean pierre pernaut ad 71 ans
[Musique]
vous l'avez entendu dans le sujet le
sommet d'europe et de défense se tiendra
au château de versailles la semaine
prochaine les abords du monument seront
répartis en plusieurs zones
conditionnant la circulation des piétons
ainsi que celles des véhicules alors
celle que vous allez voir en rouge sur
la carte sera totalement interdite aux
piétons et aux véhicules même stationner
salon rend sera autorisé le piéton avec
motif valable d'accès comprenez domicile
rendez vous médical ou commerce des
dispositifs de filtrage seront mis en
place la circulation sera ponctuellement
interrompue sur une partie du boulevard
de la reine les avenues de l'europe de
saint cloud est des états unis est à
noter que la gare de versailles rive
gauche sera fermée du jeudi 10 mars 10h
au vendredi 11 mars 18h les lignes de
bus seront 1re diriger la situation en
ukraine continue de mobiliser les
visible ynwa jean michel fourgous maire
d'elancourt proposera au vote du conseil
municipal du 8 avril prochain une
subvention exceptionnelle de 10000 euros
l' enveloppe sera en faveur de la
croix-rouge intervenant auprès de
familles et la ville en partenariat que
le département des yvelines organise
aussi une collecte solidaire les dons
produits d'hygiène matériel de couchage
ou encore aliments non périssables sont
à déposer à l'agora du lundi au samedi
avant le 19 mars
c'est le moment de retrouver votre
rubrique légal checking pour vérifier ce
que disent les acteurs de l'actualité
c'est avec le collectif les surligneurs
raphaël mata duvignau décrypte
aujourd'hui une proposition du candidat
la france insoumise jean luc mélenchon
rendait inéligibles à vie après une
condamnation pour corruption
et jean luc mélenchon souhaite rendre
inéligible à vie toute personne
condamnée pour corruption en 2017 il
proposait déjà une telle peine en toute
personne condamnée par la justice ne
serait ce qu'une seule fois et pour
n'importe quel motif mais depuis sa
condamnation pour injures publiques et
diffamation là manifestement conduit à
restreindre le champ d'application de sa
proposition
aujourd'hui d'après le code pénal la
peine complémentaire d'inéligibilité est
déjà prononcés lorsqu'une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique ou
chargée d'une mission de service public
a été condamné pour manquement au devoir
de probité comme par exemple pour
corruption d'autres délits sont
également concernés comme détournement
de fonds publics et plusieurs
personnalités politiques sont
régulièrement condamnées à de telles
peines pour de tels motifs mais en
vérité cette elle n'est pas obligatoire
puisque le code pénal précise aussi que
le juge peut décider de ne pas prononcer
la peine encourue en considération des
circonstances de l'infraction et de la
personnalité de leurs auteurs si tout
est donc ici affaire de circonstances de
l'espèce et le juge dispose d'un
véritable pouvoir d'appréciation ce qui
est soulignons le salutaire pour une
justice indépendante et démocratique
donc rendre cette peine automatique
serait contraire au principe général
d'individualisation des peines en sacré
est reconnu par le conseil
constitutionnel
par ailleurs conformément à l'article 8
de la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen toute peine doit être
proportionnée c'est pourquoi cette
inéligibilité elle qu'elle existe
actuellement est limitée à dix ans pour
les personnes exerçant un mandat électif
public ou une fonction au sein du
gouvernement en outre il faut pouvoir
tenir compte là encore des circonstances
de l'espèce d'où le nécessaire pouvoir
d'appréciation du juge
donc rendre automatique et permanente
une telle haine heurte les principes
constitutionnels élémentaires et
seraient censurées hall jusqu'au ciel
mais aussi probablement par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
nous avions déjà surligner sa
proposition en 2017 rebelote en 2022
décidément jean luc mélenchon ne
l'oublient pas
le parcours a été dévoilé à versailles
le 5 janvier dernier paris-nice partira
cette année encore des yvelines deux
villes sont à l'honneur et les maires
sont avec nous familles damerdji maire
de mantes la ville et daniel bon tu le
maire d'auffargis bonjour à tous les
deux
[Musique]
alors à quelques heures du départ je
vais voir d'avant de monsieur d'énergie
qui est le merde donc l'avis de première
première étape c'est l'impatience qui
prédomine où il ya encore tellement de
choses à penser
mon quasiment quasiment tout est
installé le
descendre est présent que manquer
gens prêts à accueillir l'ensemble des
animations qui commenceront demain
et pour donc
72 allez on va dire 48 heures 48 heures
de des plats des sorts et
cyclistes
et vous daniel bon du côté de farges is
ça va arriver lundi vous vous êtes
comment vous êtes prêts nous sommes
prêts nous aussi nous avons des
activités le dimanche après midi pour
les enfants mais pour le la dignité
alors ça mesdames hergé la ville et dont
la première étape s'est porté candidat
qu'est-ce qui vous intéressait à
recevoir à cette course
est avec nous sommes arrivés donc en
2001 on s'est positionné effectivement
pour
un événement sportif majeur
international
80e paris-nice et
les baumes c'est le treizième
département des yvelines alors
effectivement notre ville a eu un passé
un passé industriel
on aimerait donc redynamiser la ville
elle à remettre la remettre en lumière
c'est donc je suis
via industriel qui a commencé
[Musique]
instruments à vent et dans les années 50
avec des entreprises d entreprise qui
fabriquait et
de bateaux si on lançait et remettre en
lumière notre lui ça mais aussi
justement la lumière ça sera diffusée
sur france télévisions c'est la première
étape si d'habitude c'est un simple est
un prologue aussi mais vous faites
départs et arrivées si j'imagine que ça
renforce
la visibilité
effectivement c'est une boucle de 160 km
12 ha qui s'appelle jacques chirac
aujourd'hui en friche mais qui sera le
terminus du rer et donc qui sera amené à
être développé donc c'est un clin d'oeil
évidemment on était un espoir de
développement cette course donc partira
depuis de plusieurs boulevards qui est
là qui nous va roger salengro et après
une boucle 160km arrivera donc toujours
social bull va
rejoindre le lendemain ville je suis des
yvelines dans fargier alors le lendemain
c'est une tradition le lundi est la
course part d'une petite ces communes du
département aux farges et c'est un peu
moins de 2000 habitants comment est
attendue la course à daniel vente
nous sommes ravis d'accueillir
paris nice je dirais que j'ai un pas que
nous sommes habitués mais presque aucun
cycliste parce que souvent le tour de
france passe ranger le paris-nice
associe assez fréquemment à frangy pour
une bonne raison c'est que nous sommes
une commune du parc naturel d'un raid
chevreuse et nous sommes tout proches
doivent être heureuse qui en est fait
ainsi que des coureurs à prendre ces
belles routes voilà vallonné et
tourmenté c'est ce qui fait le charme
montre plusieurs coureurs du peloton
professionnel s'entraîne d'ailleurs sur
ces routes sam et d'allergies ç'a un
impact j'imagine sur la circulation de
la commune il a fallu repenser un petit
peu tout ça
bien évidemment aujourd'hui de 22
équipes donc déjà 22 bus qu'il faut
pouvoir aligner
les mêmes soucis mais comme je disais
donc c'est une zone on est donc il quand
même urbaine avec beaucoup de problèmes
de circulation ou avons tour des gars
comme c'est autour de la gare il ya
effectivement un certain nombre de
problèmes de circulation on a également
les travaux du rer eole qui qui arrive
donc ça fait deux choses de choses en
même temps néanmoins les administrés
donc
compréhensif avoir son contente qu'on
puisse quand les communes ou les verts
alors est ce que tous les deux vous êtes
passionné de cyclisme
monsieur votants premier peut-être oui
moi tout gamin me savais que auffargis a
accueilli le grand prix des nations
puisque nous avons eu la chance d'avoir
comme maire félix lévitan qui était
directeur du tour de france et qui a
fait en sorte que leur prix des nations
qui était une course contre la montre
parts d'auffargis et quelques années
cette course a été supprimé mais à
l'époque c'était un événement et puis
comme je vous le dis nous avons beaucoup
de face exactement des courses qui
traverse
tous que la liste des engagés plutôt
belle c'est assez habituel sur cette
course on peut nommer sonny colbrelli
chez les sprinters philippe au ghana
chez les rouleurs nairo quintana pour le
général les français ne sont pas en
reste david gaud duval entendre madouas
voir guillaume atteint gestationnel il
n'y a pas de julian alaphilippe cette
année merci à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation
je le rappelais vous êtes c'est lé maire
de mantes la ville et d'auffargis vous
accueillez tous les deux les deux
premières étapes du 80ème paris nice on
continue à parler de ce fameux parrainer
ce avec bixente qui nous a rejoint en
plateaux les vallons peut se vivre
autrement pas seulement soutenant les
coureurs oui puisque paris nice c'est
au-delà d'une course un événement festif
et populaire pour l'occasion le
département des yvelines a fait déployer
dans la commune de mantes la ville un
village d'animations durant tout le
week-end des 5 et 6 mars pour en parler
avec nous à alexandra faucomprez nous a
rejoint par visioconférence bonjour
[Musique]
alexandra vous êtes chargé de mission
sport et itinérance douce vous avez
contribué à la mise en place de ce
village de programmes beaucoup
d'animations bien évidemment lié au vélo
entre essais de bmx show devait été
atelier mécanique c'est vraiment voilà
une manière de fêter le vélo de cet
événement
effectivement c'est le début de l'année
paris nice finalement comment cette
cette belle année vélo je voulais déjà
remercier monsieur le maire de mende
sans qui ce village ne pourrait pas
avoir lieu beaucoup d'animations ont été
justement pris en charge et mis en place
par monsieur le maire et ses équipes
cette collaboration s'est très bien
s'est très bien passé le village se
monte petit à petit donc on est content
effectivement on va avoir pas mal
d'animations ludiques des animations
pédagogiques de prévention de sécurité
alors pour tous pour tout le monde et je
pense que beaucoup seront convertis au
vélo après ce village oui justement ce
village il est destiné acquis aux
amateurs de vélo mais où tout le monde
les familles sont effectivement famille
aussi on a pensé vraiment à tous les
publics sur ces sur ces animations va
avoir des animations pour les tout
petits avec des 13e un manège du tour de
france aussi qui est assez assez ludique
et puis on monte progressivement avec du
vtt trial des initiations ceux qui
voudront être un petit peu plus dans le
freestyle pourront faire le l'airbag en
fait crystal justement pour d'autres
découvrir d'autres disciplines
le paris nice est une course du coup de
cyclisme sur route sur ce village on
trouvera divers activités autour du vélo
comme vous le disais c'est une vraiment
une terre de vélo on voit aux jeux
olympiques de paris de 24 il y aura
plusieurs le bénisse le vtt passeront
ici le le paris nice est accueilli
depuis plusieurs années aussi dans les
yvelines c'est important d'entretenir ce
lien par des villages d'animation des
événements comme ça oui effectivement
donc c'est bien c'est bien là la
treizième année le département accueille
ce paris nice pour cette 80e édition
nous sommes une terre de vélo nous avons
plus de 1000 km de circulation douce
nous avons trois itinéraires cyclables
nationaux donc le pari mont saint michel
la scène à vélo le paris-londres à vélo
on a vraiment on cherche aussi
finalement à cultiver ce vélo fin avec à
huy à faire de cette culture du vélo sur
le sur le département et donc c'est ses
courses cyclistes nous permet justement
d'entretenir ce lien avec nos
populations locales et donc de les
amener petit à petit au vélo et encore
une fois chacun son rythme et bien sûr
voilà un village d'animations avec comme
l'un des points forts le grand départ de
dimanche la possibilité de suivre la
course avec des écrans géants c'est
l'objectif des écrans géants ressemble
rassembler le monde
ou à mantes-la-ville exactement il le
podium d'ailleurs sera installée sur le
village d'animations ont vraiment tout
le monde puisse profiter de cet
événement pour la présentation des
coureurs dimanche dès 11 heures 30 avec
vraiment ce lien tout le village a été
tourné vers le podium d'arrivée et puis
effectivement le fait qu'on ait cette
boucle permet vraiment aux populations
locales de profiter à fond de cette
course paris nice merci beaucoup
alexandra faucomprez est chargé de
mission sport au département des
yvelines et vous étiez d'ailleurs en
direct du village d'animations qui
encadrera tout le week-end l'événement
du paris-nice départ de la course
dimanche aux alentours de 12h15
mélanie on parle du paris nice je sais
que vous appréciez tout particulièrement
le vélo un favori pour la première étape
eh ben mon coeur de française aurait
voulu être supportrice pour arnaud
démare mais notre ancien champion de
france n'est pas là donc je vais me
tourner peut-être bryan coquard serait
mon petit plaisir mais je me tourne
plutôt vers sonny colbrelli ou sam
bennett le vainqueur de la première
étape l'année dernière à saint cyr
l'école le pitch ntation changer de
monture et qu'on monte sur une scène un
peu plus haute exactement alors ce n'est
plus un euro mais c'est tout aussi
robuste mélanie la randonnée équestre
est possible dans les yvelines du côté
de la forêt de rambouillet que vous
soyez débutant ou confirmé cheval nature
vous emmène à la découverte de la
deuxième plus grande forêt d'île de
france notre journaliste matt hill de
franco a mis le pied à l'étrier pour
vous regardez vous êtes peut-être un
adepte des randonnées à pied mais
connaissez-vous les randonnées à cheval
aujourd'hui on va tester la randonnée
équestre dans la forêt de rambouillet
c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je me trouve chez cheval
nature aux tartes godrans avec lenny
gallego bonjour bonjour vous faites du
coup bas niveau confirmé mais aussi
niveau débutant comment ça se passe
comment faut venir habillés
qu est ce qu on doit apporter et ban ou
alors pour les débutants qui n'ont rien
on dit toujours jean baskets ou
équivalent pas se prendre trop la tête
nous on va prêter casque mini champ's
manteau de pluie petit peu pour que pour
qui sait pas besoin d'investir pour me
remonter à cheval le but c'est de venir
te faire plaisir de découvrir le cheval
puis nous apprendre adapte le niveau et
la durée en fonction du niveau des
cavaliers 6,6 et des débutants ont fait
des petites balades d'une heure une
heure et demie on pas avec
éventuellement un petit peu trop en
fonction des gens puis bon après avec le
niveau on va élever un peu les allures
et puis faire deux heures un peu plus
avec du trot et de galop pour les gens
qui savent monter merci beaucoup je n'ai
ni gallego nous on va se retrouver tout
de suite à cheval du coup pour découvrir
la forêt de rambouillet d'une autre
manière c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du coup est-ce qu'on est là déjà
et qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial cette
forêt rambouillet à les très grands
[Musique]
très variés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà cette journée est finie vous
insérez un petit peu plus maintenant sur
les randonnées équestres au coeur des
yvelines maintenant les chevaux sont
rentrés et c'est aussi l'heure pour moi
d'aller me décrotter
[Musique]
à présent bixente une exposition dans le
sud yvelines c'est hélium qui nous la
propose oui exactement pendant les trois
premiers week end de mars l'espace la
chapelle de clairefontaine en yvelines
accueille l'exposition grand-angle
présenté par l'association d'artistes de
la vallée de chevreuse hélium début ce
samedi 5 mars pour terminer la
préparation à temps les exposants de
l'association s'activent afin d'achever
la mise en place reportage on se
retrouve du coup avec un ensemble
d'artistes qui ont pas forcément marcher
sur un sujet identique mais finalement à
créer un ensemble vraiment remis un
accrochage mise en scène cadrage à
l'association hélium on est artiste
maison met aussi la main à la pâte pour
installer une exposition nous sommes
soixante huit artistes à participer à
cette exposition collective
c'est un challenge parce que ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'oeuvres beaucoup de
l'univers beaucoup de directions de
travail à mettre les uns à côté des
autres mais ça donne une vitrine une
vraie un vrai panorama sur sur ce qu'est
il ya mais ces artistes
68 exposants à l'espace la chapelle de
clairefontaine pour une exposition
grand-angle qui regroupe peintures
sculptures photographies mais aussi des
oeuvres plus singulières fait de terre
et de pierres ce tableau que je présente
en fait ils s'appellent topographe ya
l'histoire que voilà je vais essayer de
raconter c'est que dans un futur qui va
être malheureusement assez proches ont
c'était d'imaginer que des gens vont
faire des fouilles archéologiques la
terre a repris ses droits et que quand
on va creuser en fait dans le sol on va
retrouver les constructions
d'aujourd'hui à l'extérieur de
l'enceinte un artiste travaille à
l'écart afin de mettre en valeur la
nature je réalise les grandes peintures
que j'appelle du bambou land art parce
que ce sont des grandes peintures tendue
sur des bambous arc et il me reste aussi
à attendre le vent parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand le soleil bien
sûr joue sur les couleurs et que le vent
soulève l'étoile l'effet ondulé alors là
c'est absolument magnifique
l'exposition grand-angle sera un accès
libre dès ce samedi 5 mars pour les
trois premiers week-ends du mois
c'est l'heure des agendas pour la
semaine prochaine du site et vous
commencez en chansons oui vendredi
prochain c'est le début de la deuxième
édition du versailles live c'est un
tremplin de jeunes talents neuf groupes
ont été sélectionnés et sont répartis en
trois dates le 22 avril le 20 mai est
donc le 11 mars rendez vous à 20h à la
salle de la vo de versailles pour trois
premiers concerts apollon daniel mist et
sainte-victoire l'année dernière deux
mille cinq cents personnes étaient
venues assister à la finale du tremplin
remporté par casar et joe les
récompenses c'est quand même un an de
distribution gratuite et limitée sur les
plateformes de streaming ou encore
l'opportunité de clôturer la fête de la
musique place du marché notre dame à
versailles pour un concert filmé et
monté en live et on se quitte avec un
avant goût de l'été un peu de chaleur
oui rendez vous à la plage ou du moins
dans ces villes privilégiée des
touristes pour des vacances farniente au
bord de la mer sous un parasol
l'exposition tous à la plage débute
samedi 12 mars prochain
elle retrace l'histoire des villes
balnéaires du xviiie siècle à nos jours
produite dans la cité de l'architecturé
elle dépend l'évolution des attentes
autour du bord de mer autrefois hostile
c'est devenu de nos jours une
destination privilégiée pour les
vacances d'été merci de visiter il ne
nous reste plus qu à noter tout ça dans
nos agendas c'est la fin de ce set
week-end merci de nous avoir suivi
l'information locale revient lundi en
direct avec le journal de la rédaction à
18h10 il a passé un très bon week end
sur tv 78
[Musique]